- [Gary] We are here.
We are here.
Where do we go?
That way?
How are you?
Are we eventually
going that way?
Is it just right through there?
Morning.
Yeah.
(upbeat rock music)
25?
This is it.
Wow.
Pretty cool, huh?
- [Man] Not bad.
- My man.
This is literally the
first time I've been here.
- (laughs) No way.
- This is first
time I've been here.
- This is it.
I've never been here before.
Hey Skye.
Give me a kiss.
So thankful.
- [Skye] Yes.
It's the big day.
I'm so excited.
- [Gary] It's so crazy, huh?
Wow.
Jesus.
This is so cool.
What's this?
So cool.
The office is so intense.
Look at this, Statue of Liberty.
These people have
sick seats, right?
Caldwell, Davis, Glennon.
Hook a right.
What's all that?
I want to see it.
Holy shit.
What the fuck?
This is amazing.
This is so legit.
I can't even believe
this is our office.
Is this insane?
- Yeah.
- This is how we do all hands?
We're looking right at
the Statue of Liberty.
- [Man 2] I know, it's amazing.
- This is it.
We did it.
All right, my
room is legit, guys.
I didn't even want to
look at it I'm so excited.
The Garden, baby.
Yes, it's so cozy.
This is so cool.
You guys set it up proper.
I love it.
This is where
we're gonna do a show.
Hey everybody to
Gary Vay-ner-chuk.
This is it.
My office.
All my stuff.
This is the new backdrop
for The #AskGaryVee Show.
Hey everybody this
is Gary Vay-ner-chuk.
Misha, Xander this is
daddy's new office.
Look at this, all my stuff.
There's DRock.
What you think, Horace?
- It's phenomenal.
- I love that there's all the
conference rooms by my office.
I swing here and I can
see a lot of people.
It's going to be a lot
easier to get you guys.
I guess I'll just here, right?
- [Tyler] Did you go downstairs?
- No.
- [Tyler] We're gonna go left.
- [Gary] Hi guys.
- Morning. How are you?
- [Gary] Morning.
- Morning.
How are you?
Oh is this like,
this is amazing.
I have no idea.
Were going to have to,
there's probably some sort of...
Morning, brother.
- What's going on?
- [Gary] Hey.
- [Group] Hey Gary.
- [Gary] Good morning.
- [Woman] Morning.
- [Gary] Morning.
Crazy, right?
- This is good stuff, man.
Holy shit.
- Look at the
Garden right there.
- [Man 3] Yeah,
it's right there.
- [Gary] It's right there.
- Good morning.
- [Gary] Good morning.
- Wow, wow.
- It's exciting.
- [Gary] It's crazy.
This is the first I've been here.
- I'm gonna be so inspired here.
- [Gary] You think?
I'm inspired regardless.
I can be inspired,
I can be inspired if
they put me in like a jail cell.
Have you been yet?
- [Man 4] No.
- This is so awesome.
- [Andy] It's insane.
- Wild.
- This is wild.
That's like a
good way to put it.
Look how sick this is Zhang.
Zhang little different than
BuddyMedia conference room.
Oh man, this is so
awesome, DRock.
Wait 'til it's 11 o'clock
here and it's buzzing.
You want to sit in my office?
(woman laughs)
You sure?
I'm Gary.
- Oh hi, I'm Artie
nice to meet you.
- [Gary] Artie.
- Hey Roamy.
- [Gary] Roamy, how are you?
Good.
Do you know if on 25 or 24?
- Oh, we're
definitely on this floor.
- Got it.
Yeah, there's,
okay good, good luck.
This is super fun.
Ooh, I have a Pele signed jersey.
- [DRock] Yeah.
- I didn't even know that.
This is great.
I feel like gonna do damage.
I feel like I could see
your face now so much more.
I feel like that's at
least 8 to 9 more viral hits.
I think there's a lot
in the Elvis Durant.
Today's a very special day.
Today VaynerMedia moves
in to its new office.
And I'm very excited about it.
Andy K got his seat.
DRock's got his normal
spot regardless of office.
Look how sick this is.
Look at this conference room.
Hudson Yards.
Big new project.
Jersey, love it.
Madison Square Garden.
That close. Love it.
Oh Michael Roma
got a big time seat.
Seriously, on a clear day
that's going to be unbelievable.
There's the Statue of Liberty.
Boom.
How sick is that to see the
Statue of Liberty on a nice day?
At 9 AM right here on Facebook
I'm launching a video that
I think pretty much everybody
in the world needs to see,
it's called August.
It drops today, it's very,
very important for all of you.
We're getting to
another great part.
What this little area?
You love this.
Are you 100 present stand up?
- Yeah.
- [Gary] This is you?
- All the time, yeah.
- Wait a minute,
this whole desk is you?
- [Woman 2] No, it's Shauna too.
- [Gary] It's two.
I was gonna say
that's a lot, too much.
What do you have to say
to the Vayner Nation?
- So happy to be here.
This been a long time
coming and it's amazing.
- [Gary] And what
about this picture?
- Oh, these are Golden Girls
these are my favorite thing in
the entire world.
Love you.
- [Gary] Love it.
Love you more.
- This is beautiful.
- [Gary] Honestly the company
started in a conference
room like that.
That size.
- [DRock] Wild.
- [Gary] This conference room,
me, Zhang, Marcus and AJ and
definitely not
this kind of view.
You know what's great about this
conference room is first of all,
the views are so ridiculous but
this conference room's perfect
for my morning leadership
meetings because if you're late
for it and you come through
there we can all see, it's a,
yeah, it's a whole weird thing.
Pretty cool.
Big day. Pretty
excited about it.
Hey Nate.
This is nuts.
Have you been here?
- No.
- [Gary] Me neither.
- This is insane.
- [Gary] I'm freaking out.
Did you see the caf?
- The caf?
- Cafeteria?
- Oh yeah, I walked through it.
- The kitchen.
Is that where you got that?
- [Nate] No I went
to the coffee place.
- Snapchat, go to Facebook right
now check my new August video.
Share that shit up,
it's important.
- It's going to be a good one.
- This is ridiculous.
- [Gary] Is it unbelievable?
- Unbelievable.
- [Gary] Did you see my office?
- Yeah, I'm sitting
in there right now.
- [Gary] Got it.
Did you see the cafeteria?
- [Brandon] I walked through it.
I had no idea.
- I had no idea, too.
I've never been here.
- Get out of here.
- I've never been here.
(laughs) That's how I roll.
- I came in today I'm
like it's new building
it's probably pretty nice.
You know, blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah.
I came up, I mean look at this.
- [Gary] I mean the views,
I mean the Statue of Liberty.
Happy birthday, bro.
- Thank you.
- [Gary] You're welcome.
- [Man 5] Morning.
How are you?
- Thank you.
- [Gary] Unbelievable, huh?
- It's great.
- [Man 6] Gary the
internet is sick.
- [Gary] Yes, finally.
It's the first
time I've heard that.
How did you guys win the lotto?
This is insane.
Holy shit.
Yeah, you're gonna
be okay with this?
You're gonna be good with this?
- I'm gonna be good with this.
- [Gary] I'm Gary.
Such a pleasure.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] Is this like an
official meeting here?
- Yes.
- Like you guys booked it?
- [Man 7] Yeah.
- [Gary] Like today?
You just press, what you do?
This conference
room is so ridiculous.
Ty!
Where's my meeting in Godzilla?
- It's amazing.
All the smiles, it's just
like the smiles.
- [Gary] Dude, the
Statue of Liberty.
That's my favorite part.
- [Man 8] Gary, how's it going?
- [Gary] Really well.
'Sup gang?
- [Man 9] Hello.
Hey.
- [Gary] Morning.
Let's go, brother.
I love the one view you get
is the Statue of Liberty.
The one peep you get is
the Statue of Liberty.
You should literally sometimes
just and people like,--
- That's a good idea.
- just be like this and people
be like oh he's creating.
(group laughter)
He's super creating.
He's creating.
When he gets pissed he
can just be like alright,
let me just zen it out a little.
- Yeah, 100%, very accurate.
- I'm aware.
Look at that.
Get that shot.
It's literally like
flies to the light.
Pretty cool, huh, Steve?
Just like our old office.
Steve, were you in Debroses?
- [Steve] Yeah, I was.
- This is a long
way from Debroses.
You have to leave eventually.
You can't sit here forever.
- I know.
- Sorry.
Do you know how home I feel?
I literally in my office
look at Madison Square Garden.
- [Man 10] It's unreal.
- [Gary] Dude, I gotta admit
though the fucking
Statue of Liberty.
I don't know why the
Statue of Liberty,
that is fucking awesome.
- [Tyler] Brandon,
not to anyone, right?
Just signed?
- [Brandon] Yeah.
- Yep, get them.
- [Tyler] See Daniella and
see if she can come by.
- [Woman 2] It's perfect.
- [Gary] What's your
favorite flavor so far?
- Lemon.
- [Gary] Yeah.
You guys have to fix this
because I just want you to know
I am dominant in this
game, like dominant.
Like I'm all-time.
I'm Russian.
- [Man 11] There's no puck.
- [Gary] There's a puck.
So fucking cool.
I love the action
of the kitchen.
I feel like my office is
going to be the kitchen.
- There are Froot Loops.
- [Gary] This cereal
is freaking people out.
- [Man 12] There's cereal?
- No, here's my thing.
I have a real concern about
anybody that starts now.
I feel like they're going to,
I feel like they're going
to be like, yeah.
They're like, yes, I feel like
we gotta go back to something
before 373.
(group chatter)
- All new hires have to--
- [Gary] I feel like all of you
are gonna do what I do know my
children, right, be like
when we were in 315,--
(laughter)
you know what I mean?
I'm telling you right now, get
ready for a month from now you
saying to somebody who's going
to complain about something,
what? I sat in a broom closet.
- [Emily] To take
calls every day.
- [Woman 3] Shark Tank and all
of a sudden it's like Gary--
- [Woman 4] What happened?
- [Gary] We've been live
streaming the whole time.
Everybody knows everything.
Why is?
I didn't think you
watered orchids.
- No, you ice them.
- That's right.
- Tyler, good job, baby.
I was trying to catch you.
I was like you don't
water these things,
you're like no you ice them.
I'm like...
- You do.
- You're on your game.
And he's got a green thumb,
they look good or
did just get them today?
- Today.
(light music)
I'll tell you, look
how cool this is.
Look how ridiculous this is.
We're like by far
the smallest company.
- [Woman 4] Can
we get a picture?
- [Woman 3] That's so cool.
- We're running so late.
I've got to be on stage.
Take a selfie.
(light music)
- [Man 12] Gary, my man.
How you doing, man?
- How are you?
- Nice to meet ya.
- Nice to meet you.
- [Darren] GaryVee!
- [Gary] 'Sup my brother?
- I'm Darren AKA
D-Money nice to meet you.
- [Gary] How you doin'?
Real pleasure, man.
- [Darren] Too bad you
got to rush out,
we got a really
good party afterwards.
Snoop Dogg and French Montana.
- I gotta get to LA.
- [Darren] We're gonna have
you have speak up here in a few.
- [Gary] Okay.
- Oh my God,
I went to your office.
Sign some books?
- Of course.
- How you doin'?
Neil Charles.
- Neil, nice to meet you, man.
Thank you, brother.
A quick picture real quick?
- You got it.
- [Gary] Who do you want
me to make it out to, man?
Because the end consumer is
the only thing that matters.
I really didn't want
Twitter to lose it's lead
that it had six years ago.
As a lot of you know, that's
where I really blew up from.
I'm not pumped that with
1.3 million followers that
I can't get anywhere close to
the conversion that I did
five years ago or six years ago
with 150,000 or
200,000 followers.
It's just attention arbitrage.
- That's awesome, thanks Gary.
- [Gary] Alexi!
- Yeah
- Why are you taking all
the credit for her work?
- [Alexi] I'm just
the executioner.
- It's nice to meet you.
- [Woman 3] I watch all your
videos in like two days.
- I'm so sorry.
- So intense.
- I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
Hey.
Real pleasure. It was fun to
hang over the weekend.
Awesome.
- Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- [Man 13] Can we
get a quick picture?
- [Gary] Yeah.
(speaking Russian)
Not only from the
same place he is...
- I tweeted it.
The first time...
- [Man 14] Catch that plane.
- Thank you brother.
- [Man 14] Good luck, man.
- [Gary] Take care of yourself.
Take care guys.
Thank you for coming.
Stay well.
Thank you.
Thank you brother.
Wish you well.
- Thanks Gary.
- Take care, man.
Jordan, let's go.
Am I on the vlog right now?
- Is it a blog or is it a vlog?
- [Man 15] Are we in
the vlog right now?
- [Gary] Yep.
- [DRock] Uh-huh. Yep.
- Hell yeah.
- [Gary] How are you, my man?
- Very good.
- [Gary] Good to see you.
Thank you guys.
Stay well.
Thank you.
47 is this it?
This could be my guy.
Yep, it's me.
Yeah. So crazy babe, yeah.
I can't wait for you to see it.
(light music)
- I'm Jason.
I'm going to be
flying you today.
- Thank you, my man. Gary.
- Gary, I'll need to see
everybody's IDs.
- [Jordan] Have a good night.
- Alright guys, hop on in.
- [Gary] Thank you.
(light music)